and I'm telling you now if you've got a
hay fever or anything like that these
are great hi I'm Joshua Connor and these
are my essentials
my campervan who I call Winnie she used
to be called Winston I don't have her
here so this is a photograph of her you
can see a little glimpse into the inside
that's a wood burning stove that's a
fridge to refrigerate things that's a
sink to wash things you get the gist and
I lived in Winnie for a lot of last year
I was shooting a film called La Camara
in Italy and when he doesn't have a
shower but I was camping out by Lake
bolsena which is a very beautiful Lake
in the middle of Italy and I washed
myself in the lake and the only way to
get shopping food was to use a canoe to
go into the nearby Village so I was very
fit and healthy for the end of it so my
next item is this scrapbook I've been
keeping scrapbooks for films and
projects and characters for quite a long
time and this is one of them this is the
first page of my lucky mirror scrapbook
La Mary is about a man called Arthur an
archaeologist and he's digging for old
Etruscan treasures and selling them to
museums for lots of money and it's a
kind of pirate trade in the 80s but
really Arthur is searching for the soul
of his lost fiancee he died but also for
something Beyond life something that
doesn't exist but whether it's death or
the Unseen or something like that and so
a lot of my research was just about our
relationship to afterlife or to death
sounds very miserable but it wasn't it
was very joyful and the Etruscans saw
life after death as more meaningful than
life itself and I feel like nowadays we
have less of a connection to
spirituality and that notion so that was
really interesting there's actually a
poem that Elite the director gave to me
when we started this film and then
there's all sorts of bits in here like
obviously images but I also will keep
like bits of moss and lichen there's
some of my drawings like bits of
material there's all sorts of stuff in
here but it's mostly about character
stuff and bits of writing that I found
and poems and images I like and that was
a flower that I tried to glue in anyway
so this is one of my scrapbooks this
one's a very precious one to me because
lucky Mara was a very precious film to
me
[Music]
next essential item is this camera I am
by no means a good photographer so I
don't really know too much about it I'm
pretty sure there's there's all sorts of
bits on here that I don't really
understand I will take it around me when
I go in the van sometimes I really only
take it when I go off camping or with
mates the only time I used it
professionally I once took photos of my
friend Jesse Buckley using this camera
and that was really good because I was
showing off to Jesse making I think that
I was a professional photographer and I
wasn't they very kindly gave me a
photograph assistant and he just told me
how to do everything
sounds good so my next essential item is
copy decks which is a glue a strong
adhesive for Fabrics crafts carpets DIY
solvent free acid free and easy to use
didn't know any of those things but
you'll I'll tell you what
I'll just open up for you so it's kind
of you can see it's sort of liquidy
we've got quite a horrible smell to it
actually but this stuff is amazing my
grandmother used to use this I remember
seeing it in her Studio but it's really
good for if you like scrapbooking which
I do
like this one it's really good for
sticking in photographs or anything
really it just does sort of do
everything one thing I discovered it
doesn't do is are flowers like in my
Nakamura scrapbook because it just
doesn't seem to work so good for most
things not good for if you wanted to
stick a flower somewhere
and then these scrapbooks are personal
scrapbooks and just images and letters
that I've sent or received or things
that I like over the years one of the
images in this scrapbook is of the
artist Eve Klein Eve Klein was obsessed
with the color blue the image is him
jumping off this high wall trying to
capture blue because the blue in the sky
and the idea behind it is that the
artist needs to take a leap of faith
sometimes in order to capture the idea
the the form that they're looking for
when I first moved to London I was
working three or four jobs I was trying
to audition trying to make it as an
actor so I quit my jobs and my mum was
very concerned and thought you're not
going to thrive very long in London
without a job I got that postcard and I
wrote on the back of it and said
sometimes as an artist we need to take a
leap of faith she still has it on her on
the fireplace at home second image very
quickly is a photograph
Helen is a friend and I love her I wrote
to her when I was 14 15. having read
this book and I sent it to Helen the
Bonham Carter there were all these
characters and I thought oh well Helena
could play that such and such could play
this and then there's this young lad
who's gonna play that and I just left a
picture of my face and my very short CV
which was like doing The Wizard of Oz in
year six that was on the final page so
the idea being that she'd finish the
book and she'd go but this is great but
who's going to play the young lad I
don't think she did I know she didn't
because I've since become a friend of
hers but she sent me that note and I've
kept ever since it says Dear Josh thank
you for the book good luck Hannah
Montana it's just quite a nice thing
my next item are these face
rolling
devices Petra who makes me look really
nice and normal hopefully when I do
things like this used these recently in
can and they were actually Lush they're
so nice and you just pop them on your
face
and roll them about and yeah you put
them in the fridge they're nice and cold
and I'm telling you now if you've got
hay fever or anything like that these
are great
some of my Ceramics they're essential
because I really like them this is a
ceramic by my grandmother I love it very
much and my grandmother passed away a
couple of years ago and she was an
incredible woman and I was left this and
it's very beautiful and I've got to
figure out how to hang it but at the
moment it's sort of rested at home but I
really love it and I actually love the
wood that it's attached to I think it's
very handsome thing so then the next one
this is a very brilliant British
ceramicist called Ian Godfrey and this
is one of his cityscapes
it's actually a lidded vessel so you can
see it's sort of like six escapes and
you've got these animals but if you open
it up you get a little treat with these
birds
that sit inside I love it very much and
now this is very important because it
was given to me by my friend Jonathan
it's by an artist called Lucy Rhee who's
perhaps one of the most celebrated
ceramicists I'm not a big collector of
things so I'm in no way looking to
collect a load of stuff I just like the
idea of looking after these precious
objects
and they're just nice to look at on me
my next item is matcha Leaf a tree
memory game very simple concept you get
a load of trees like here we have beech
tree here then you have the leaf thereof
of the beech tree so you put them all
the cards over like this and scatter
them around there's loads of them
so you go Beach tree and then you've got
this memory games you've got to remember
where the leaf of the beach tree is
there's the leaf of the beech tree and I
appreciate it sounds very basic and
perhaps tedious but if you like trees
like me it's not it's really enjoyable
these running shoes oh here we go adizer
adios Pro threes they're extremely light
and I don't know if you'll be able to
see in this light but they're kind of
like see almost see through it it's like
a I don't know what the material is
they're amazing but anyway they're
essential because I use them to go
running and I actually ran the London
Marathon for the first time this year in
these for a great charity called the
Samaritans they're very nice I mean I
supposedly they're yeah they're they're
race shoes which I guess that means you
use them for things like marathons I
feel quite cool wearing them actually
and that's it thank you very much for
watching